how's it going risk my name is Pierre
Dubois and welcome back to Octodad if
you haven't watched the first part go
ahead and click the screen right now or
the link in the description it's a
really awesome intro and it needs to be
watched I'll see you there I'm so sorry
welcome wait last manager how's it going
right - perfect
welcome to Octodad dadliest catch we
play this a while ago it came out with a
full version today yes I'm so excited
for this game this is obviously the game
of the year every year ever I see it has
co-op mode that's [ __ ] awesome I
gotta try that out but not today I can
continue really nice hat that guy has
stopped the chef what do I do
got it go get oh yes
get off number toe second gnome and he
fainted because he's so sad a blob of
force what the hell not okay Oh
groceries we need to go to the grocery
store we need things like cereal for the
kids it's a trap that kids already have
cereal we need so much cereal then it's
settled
we're all going to the grocery store
it's a crap
I want what Johnson I wonder if they all
actually knew that he was not the
president they're just pretending that
they don't know just to make him happy
that would probably I bet that's a plot
twist in the end or some [ __ ] like that
it's like yeah we we know you're an
octopus that we're not [ __ ] I wonder
if there's a backstory as to why he's a
dad in octopus that would be funny - I'm
curious if the thing will actually have
a story or not it seems like it at least
so now we're at the grocery sorry [ __ ]
yeah I love the grocery store you can
pick food and [ __ ] excuse me I'm coming
through god I hate that it's like
goddamn it I gotta do everything now did
you know that one octopus which can
what are you doing nothing I'm not doing
anything
hey BAE you know I have a wife but look
at these this is what you could be
having look at it hey girl this is what
you're missing out on okay let's get get
me so [ __ ] we have acted and vicious
as an octopus can I come with you
what are we going why are we going all
right we're going adventure take me come
on let's go baby I'm ready my body is
ready
literally hello he crawls up to people
yes what does it look like I'm doing my
minecraft in a grocery store what that
fukk chocolate mine claim
I want the creeper face give me the
paper face oh no oh no it's gonna blow
time for the big game maybe for a big
party only Gerson's has a soda city big
enough to handle all your biggest events
obtain mango soda this is gonna be tough
mad okay our Delhi offer right now now
that could be flattened by roasted and
toasted so hard why does life have to be
so difficult
no I swear to God
yes yes fly baby fly on the wings of
love fly on the wings of octopus baby oh
my god
what is happening how does how do I even
okay yes them skills is amazing why did
I go on down here
hi I'm I'm a but chocolate milk okay got
it
this milk says it's packed with vitamin
G now my mate just gotta grab the milk
now God come on now you're just playing
with me
oh this shop the shop yeah okay now it's
all octo daddy's yellow [ __ ] I got you
now yes that milk company in the AAA
milk that makes sense okay hey our
freezer section is all frozen up we're
working on getting it fixed but we're
sure at least one freezer door is
working so I'm supposed to go behind me
is that it
oh it is okay
hi have you never seen an octopus in a
freezer before it's quite common in most
countries
what am I doing with my life I never won
in this frozen pizza every change we wat
[ __ ] at the club map it's a [ __ ] my
pizza deeper dish so worth it
so worth it my pita [ __ ] my pizza
I'm stir I seem to be stuck in your all
thing but that was a make that was in a
way talking back I wonder how his suit
can stretch so well sorry about that
just need the perfect Apple great day
today isn't it perfect Apple okay our
goddess Oh does it say seananners of
course oh he's looking at me
hello the slighty effect it's [ __ ]
moonwalking oh god I hate bananas
I want to see I'll say that on on just
ends all right where's the apple god
damn II I gather you like melons
I love melons can i no that's not bean
it's not do that
help I think I broke my neck out of this
world
tentacles
it really just freaking me the [ __ ] out
I don't understand Japanese people are
into that [ __ ] I mean it is what the
banana peels are even sliding get the
sushi sample in back why does it have to
be so many bananas ah
the thing with octa debt is you can't
really tell if he's falling or if it's
just walking normally so it doesn't
really matter I guess okay get the sushi
from the back got it got it got it
ah easy but easy that's a nearly bit
it's a crab no oh it's not
moderately-priced I'm fancy as [ __ ] I
don't wear this product suit for nothing
[ __ ] alright gotta run gotta run boy
gotta go gotta go gotta do that a pantry
alright this is not the way I want to
run but life is life hey hey man
Oh God oh no I seem to be stuck the jab
anything but the jab oh man I [ __ ]
love this game this is not how a man
who's running for his life is running oh
[ __ ] not the jam not the jam this is not
my jam
okay don't get stuck yes yes baby yes
baby sexist Texas idiot that's what you
get for player hating what's he doing
oh he can't actually it's not normally
Hoover the time I didn't see them in the
entire time Oh may i hey baby when we
get back I'm gonna give you this world
check out the front
I got a self scan god this is hard
enough in real life how the hell are
gonna do this in octave day there we go
dad
chocolate milk very much happy a [ __ ] I
try sit here
well that makes two of us damn what why
are we even together oh you're not
getting any place
come on dad what are you waiting for
but the aquarium is my nightmare
all right gonna have to end there so
here if you enjoyed watching and want to
support this series please leave a like
it really helps me out a lot I really
appreciate it bros hits the sky khon
road today and i see you tomorrow with
another episode stay awesome bros love
you
you